we're confused that men women women
project constantly so we constantly
project the way we feel onto men so
we're confused that they know what they
want because we don't know what we want
like it changes every single day and
even IL logical things if we feel a
certain way it it doesn't even matter
like if we feel a certain way then we
believe it's true um and the other thing
is I think women we have no idea just
how much we really only look at the top
guys again women find find again women
find 80% of men is ugly not unattractive
not okay but ugly and women usually I
mean I think with the a million videos
we come out with all these fat chicks
saying that they're tense can come to
the conclusion that most women overrate
their beauty and think they're more
beautiful than they are